bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver comme tous les lundis
tout de suite on passe au sommaire de ce
sept huit sports course 2 course
automobile le rallye des gazelles débute
ce week-end le départ de cette course
d'orientation sera donné depuis nice là
une dizaine d'îles et me disait indivis
noise seront sur la ligne de départ nous
recevrons sur ce plateau laurence batala
et séverine sous le nez un équipage
trappistes football magny les hameaux
n'en finit plus de gagner en deuxième
division de district les joueurs de
farid gagny ont étrillé le pecq sur leur
terrain 7 buts à zéro tous les détails
dans cette édition
course à pied la 8e édition des
cotterêts il paris ile de france est
programmée ce samedi le départ sera
donné depuis l'île aux loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines
parmi les participants on retrouvera
patrick guérin qui va courir pour
l'association aliénor les coureurs
source sera soutenu par les élèves
yvelinois le sportif et les étudiants
seront avec nous dans ce journal
et puis en fin de l'émission nous
reviendrons sur tous les résultats du
week end
on commence ce journal par deux du sport
automobile le rallye des gazelles
s'élancera le samedi le 21 mars pour le
soleil marocain
cette année cent soixante huit équipages
venus de 17 pays participeront à cette
25e édition
une dizaine de participantes sont
originaires des yvelines le montage est
signée romain aarhus fini
et dunes à perte de vue des oasis
luxuriante et une chaleur étouffante
ce sera une nouvelle fois le décor du
rallye aïcha des gazelles
cette année cent soixante huit équipages
venus de 17 pays participeront à cette
25e édition
parmi les participantes on retrouvera
sur la ligne de départ une dizaine d'
illinoise dont un équipage 100%
trappistes des versaillaise mais
également l'union courtoise nous allons
partir le 21 mars de la ville de nice
métropole niçoise
nous allons aller à rabat puisque nous
aurons un deuxième départ officiel de
rabat le 24 mars et nous allons
descendre dans le grand sud marocain au
sud-est marocain pour finir à et servira
le 3 avril comme chaque année les
conditions risquent d'être une nouvelle
fois éprouvante pour les participantes
au programme réveil à 4h tous les matins
et conduite de 12 à 15 heures par jour à
travers les dunes et les rochers pour
corser le rallye la compétition se fera
sans l'assistance des moyens de
navigation au moderne
pas de gps rien pas de téléphone rien
juste carte 100.000ème une règle cra une
boussole et après ça on est au milieu de
nulle part et il faut savoir où aller
pour aller pointer ses contrôles de
passage et surtout il faut savoir poids
des ces contrôles de passage un parent
en faisant le moins de kilomètres
possible c'est à dire qu'il faut prendre
conscience qu'il faut avoir la route la
plus droite chose qui est impossible
ça s'appelle tiré au cap et en hors
piste c'est impossible donc on est tous
en train de refaire tirer son cap
redescendre regarder si on est dans le
bon cap remonter dans la voiture
repartir enlever des pierres voilà on
est en traverse des montagnes au delà de
la compétition sportive le rallye des
gazelles est avant tout une aventure
humaine pour donner confiance aux femmes
l'objectif je crois que c'était
valoriser la femme mettre en avant
toutes les capacités féminine à travers
dans un monde qui n'est pas le leur
c'est à dire le monde automobile
ça apporte une force extraordinaire à
une femme
parce qu'elle se rend compte de quoi il
est capable en attendant le début de
l'épreuve les yvelinois sont dans les
starting blocks
rendez vous le samedi 21 mars prochain
pour cette 25e édition pour nous parler
de ce rallye des gazelles nous recevons
sur ce plateau deux participantes un
équipage trappistes composé de laurence
betala est également de séverine soula
alors toutes les deux vous ne faites pas
de sport automobile ans non non c'est
notre première participation et on est
complètement novice en sport auto donc
donc au niveau même même en amateur vous
n'avez jamais partie jamais une petite
une petite course de karting peut-être
une fois ou deux et qu'est ce qui vous a
donné envie justement de vous lancer
dans cette aventure
ça fait longtemps que je regardais les
reportages sur ce rallye et un jour ça
m'a traversé un peu plus l'esprit qu'un
autre j'en ai parlé à ses origines au
cours d'un repas y voit là on a décidé
de s'engager tout les deux nos enfants
se connaissent enfin voilà par l'école
et on avait envie d'aller plus loin et
créer quelque chose sur trappe et il
investir et donc c'est plutôt vous qui
avez eu l'idée de ce projet donc
initialement oui mais c'est vrai il
n'était très branché par tout ce qui
était le maroc donc j'ai pas mis long
par la force de persuasion de laurent ça
n'a pas tardé à me faire basculer et du
coup en lui emboîter le pas mais c'est
effectivement c'est elle qui est à
l'initiative de cette participation
et comment votre entourage justement a
réagi parce qu'on sait que c'est quand
même assez difficile dans des conditions
assez extrêmes et comment votre
entourage à la gilles on lui a peut-être
un petit peu peur ils se sont interrogés
sur non sur sa maman en fait on fait en
ce qui me concerne
globalement je connaissais un petit peu
maroc j'ai déjà participé pas des
courses automobiles mais des choses un
peu extrême dans cas pas cette peur là
en fait c'était surtout l'organisation
en fin de mon côté du côté de laurent ça
a été un peu plus différent sur
l'appréhension du départ etc
de mon côté c'est plutôt sur
l'organisation et puis le temps que ça
prend c'est excessivement chronophage et
en fait on est toutes les deux mères de
famille et donc voilà nos conjoints nos
enfants ont dû eux
voilà nous soutenir et puis voilà tous
nos familles nos amis nos collègues de
bureau enfin voilà il ya eu tout un tout
un réseau qui s'est vraiment créé autour
de nous et c'est autour de ce projet et
c'est ce qui nous apportait aussi depuis
qu'on a mis en place et dont vous avez
besoin de sponsors également pour
participer à cette épreuve
oui c'est un gros budget donc on a fait
appel à des sponsors essentiellement
situés sur on a deux pôles on à la zone
trappistes et la zone de versailles
il ya xavier sylvie drouet 4e qui nous
ont beaucoup mieux et démis vraiment le
cepd le pied qui nous ont mis le pied à
l'étrier qui nous ont décidé à partir à
la fois au niveau budget mais au niveau
il faut comme un acquittement de budget
pour pour partir donc en fait là on a à
peu près un budget de 28 à 29 millions à
réunir pour pouvoir participer à cette
épreuve
du coup ça comprend quoi ces vingt-huit
mille euros c'est la voiture quinze
mille euros environ pour l'inscription
pure et ensuite bien sûr il va il faut
s'équiper en matériel voiture transferts
etc et enfin tous les emails faux frais
qui est une des formations les
formations a fait des stages de
navigation d'orientation est de 2
produite pour se préparer à l'épreuve et
donc justement comment vous ai préparé
l'épreuve
c'est un entraînement quand même à 5 ans
vous êtes préparatoire le camp ça fait
une bonne année et demi qu'on se prépare
on se prépare en faisant de la course à
pied ont fait de la course d'orientation
aussi pas mal dans le secteur donc on
dans les wagons castor avec aux castors
donc vraiment voilà pour réapprendre à
manipuler la carte et la boussole des
choses qu'on perdait un peu de vue et
puis dernièrement on a fait des stages
de navigation pure pour voilà apprendre
à manier les outils qui nous seront
nécessaires au rallye et puis de la
conduite aussi parce que ben ça
s'apprend fin ont conduit pas un 4/4
comme ont conduit notre voiture de tous
les jours donc on a fait des stages en
tout terrain et vous avez demandé des
conseils à des professionnels ou à des
fosses d'aisance et très rapidement en
fait pro rienté vers des personnes qui
avaient déjà fait ce rallye dont
constitution voilà déjà l'expérience du
rallye
donc en fait la maman de laurence a
fortuitement vu dans la rue un 4 4 qui
revenait l'année dernière du rallye des
gazelles
donc elle a gentiment posé seins qui
papier sur le pare-brise en donnant nos
coordonnées et en sollicitant donc les
deux jeunes femmes qui sont sylvette et
nathalie qui étaient partis l'année
dernière et qui nous ont supportés aussi
est donné énormément les a rencontrés
plusieurs fois c'est devenu d'ailleurs
des amis voilà
et ils nous en donner beaucoup de
renseignements elles ont pas été du tout
avare et elles ont été vraiment très
aidantes et accompagnantes sur justement
cette expérience que nous n'avons pas
comment vous disais on un peu novice
cette voiture les commandes du coup
alors cette voiture c'est un toyota et
jc une belle bête c'est vraiment elle
est folle et sous terre enfin vraiment
la tester
on l'a testé sur la plage dans l'est
dans les corbières sur les sur les
rochers et c est vraiment elle se
comporte admirablement ses lacets le
véhicule au roi pour pour ce genre
d'épreuve en fait c'est enfin de sa
toyota c4 4e n'ont cessé leur terrain de
jeu et dont il vit l'egypte et donc vous
êtes vous êtes vraiment prêtre l'art à
quelques jours de l'épreuve
alors on reste encore quelques détails à
peaufiner
je pense qu'on est en ce sens prête en
fait pour l'épreuve un peu peut-être un
peu trop épuisé justement de ces efforts
consentis travail laurence et comptable
moi je suis en train de créer mon
entreprise
donc en fait c'était tout ça qui devait
se plus la vie de famille puis plein de
plein de choses peuvent être téléchargés
voilà le temps a été chargée donc on
arrive un peu on a su un petit peu levé
le pied avant l'épuisement je pense
c'est bien là non mais là on ya quelques
jeux la région surtout hâte d'y être et
on va voir ce qu'on soit français
souffrent se confronter à ce qu'on
attende depuis longtemps ce qu'on
apprenne et donc ça va être une
compétition quand même assez difficile
avec des fortes chaleurs des dunes
il faudra sur terré et justement
qu'est-ce que vous appréhendez peut-être
le plus sur cette épreuve
le manque de sommeil justement parce que
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
très physique dense vous avez entre 12
et 15 heures parle roule entre 12 et 15
heures par jour alors il ya des temps de
pause pour pouvoir reprendre le cap etc
mais c'est vraiment un travail de
concentration pendant douze à quinze
heures par jour maintenant
l'aspect mental un petit peu enfin voilà
forest forêt vraiment rester concentré
le terrain aussi puisqu'en fait on
connaît pas du tout enfin selon l'ap hm
de prescience en fait de ce que de ce
qu'on va de ce qu'on va voir et de ce
qu'on va affronter
donc on n'a pas cette expérience
puisqu'on et je sais juste notre
première participation
donc c'est personnellement je pense
prenez voilà ce qui est quelque chose
qui nous fait un peu peur donc on a
travaillé notre team building cours des
cours d'orientation etc
on espère qu'on va on sait qu'on va
devoir les prouver au niveau psychique
et parce que quinze ans dans le même
habit tech avec la même personne c'est
pas forcément dans des conditions un peu
extrêmes ce genre un peu compliqué mais
un bond personnellement ça sens que
c'est le terrain aussi par nous la
confrontation avec le terrain qui
globalement fin ça nous angoisse
tiennent enfin ça nous questionnent nous
questionnent allons à la fois excités et
à la fois ouais un petit peu peur à dix
on l'est aussi c'est le l'excitation le
stress le bon stress en ligne et vous
allez vous relayer pendant la course où
les positions sont préétablis
donc on a pré établis en apprêterait
bino rôle en fait donc puisqu'il faut un
pilote donc laurent sera pilote
enfin une pilote donc laurence haurat
pilote et moi je serai donc à côté
d'elle pour la seconde et et la guider
donc à l'orientation
néanmoins on a prévu enfin aujourd'hui
c'est ce qui c'est ce qui nous
paraissait imprécisions et dans le souci
ou une envie particulière vie voilà j'ai
vraiment envie de naviguer aujourd'hui
ou vraiment envie de conduire
on saura se laisser la main aussi et
quels sont vos objectifs justement sur
cette compétition c'est faire plaisir
c'est participer
alors c'est plus que participer c'est se
faire plaisir vraiment en a on a fait on
a consenti beaucoup d'efforts enfin
personnellement enfin à toutes les deux
consenti énormément d'efforts à cette
préparation et pour y aller et on espère
vraiment se faire plaisir
on en est à peu près sûr parce qu'on
rencontre voilà qui pour faire honneur
aussi à nos sponsors à ceux qui nous ont
accompagnés
voilà on veut terminer
ramener la voiture correctement cette
ferait plaisir et être à la banane quoi
de revenir avec plein de l'image plein
d'idées plein de plein d'envié plein
voilà et du coup c'est aussi une
aventure humaine c'est ça l'objectif est
énormément une aventure humaine d'abord
parce qu'on va passer beaucoup enfin on
a déjà passé énormément de temps toutes
les deux et et nos familles part ça va
de soi et me voilà enfin ce et puis on
essaye de le partager
enfin avec la population de trappes on a
un rendez vous mercredi prochain à 15
heures à 15 heures sur le parvis de la
mairie pour pouvoir justement être en
contact avec avec la population avec qui
on vit au quotidien et avec qui on sent
bien donc voilà on a envie de leur
partager notre note ralentissement c'est
une aventure humaine effectivement sens
large
on ne peut pas partir tout seul déjà
environ part à deux donc mais en plus on
est obligé d'avoir enfin en plus on est
obligé on a un cercle très élargi en
fête et de sponsors d'amis de soutien
qui est très qui est très globale ça
nous a amené à rencontrer des tas de
gens et des tas de gens nous suivent
et voilà donc c'est très humain
finalement parce que tout seul on n'y
serait pas arrivé
et c'est vrai je suis intervenu vers une
seule fois où vous voulez faire
peut-être sur sur plusieurs années alors
déjà on va voir ça ça va s'élancer
voilà on va le faire une fois et
apprendre à voir c'est quand même
beaucoup de travail sur un sur un temps
un parti qui voit là ça fait un an et
demi qu'on travaille dessus
voilà qui sait peut-être que on aura une
envie folle de montrer de recommencer on
avec l'expérience qu'on a accumulé
éventuellement enfin je vous cache pas
que la partie financière et est assez
complexe à boucler un budget à boucler
c'est compliqué surtout de nos jours
voilà il y aurait ce même des petites
places pour avec quelques semaines voilà
donc ça s'est compliqué donc pour
recommencer effectivement vu l'effort
consenti il y en a plein qui recommence
donc je pense que j'espère que si ça se
passe bien on envoie à voir aussi merci
laurent se battent à la merci d'une soul
a alors vous avez également aussi un
blog 1 c'est ça vous tenez à jour votre
blog pour l'or sur facebook on peut nous
suivre l'association s'appelle rallier
new ra 2 a livré que zheng tiré à nos us
voilà vous pouvez nous suivre pendant
toute la course y compris sur le site
officiel du rallye aïcha des gazelles
on est l'équipe à 198 merci beaucoup en
tout cas d'être passé sur ce plateau et
bon courage pour la compétition pour ce
rallye merci on passe tout de suite au
football
en football magny les hameaux se
rapproche un peu plus de la montée en
première division de district les ce
dimanche les hommes de farid gagny se
sont imposés 7 buts à 0 face à l'opecst
le score final donc 7 à 0 pour les
manier quoi william head pour les images
un rouleau compresseur un festival
offensif le mani football club a livré
une superbe prestation
ce dimanche les bleu et noir ont fait
vivre un véritable enfer aux défenseurs
du pecq lors de la 15e journée de
deuxième division de district les saint
quentinois l'ont facilement emporté 7
buts à 0 avec quatre passes décisives de
leur numéro 9 nicolas rouillon le
troisième il aura fait du mal ils ont
beaucoup lâché derrière après on avait
beaucoup d'espacés joue intelligemment
en est resté en place derrière ont
pratiquement pas été en danger à part
sur une frappe à la fin sinon je vois je
crois qu'on est resté bien en bloc et on
les a laissés se détruire petit à petit
le troisième ça leur a fait du mal
psychologiquement je pense on a creusé
le trou après s'il victoire qui fait du
bien aux prises avec un score assez
fleuve
c'est vrai que depuis deux trois
semaines on était un peu moins bien mais
bon on a accumulé pas mal de matches
officiels depuis début de saison gamache
compris qui la semaine dernière contre
montigny le bon on a quand même réussi à
gagner en marquant six buts
aujourd'hui contre le dernier sept buts
on peut rassembler pas on n'est pas trop
mal quoi au classement magny les hameaux
s'envolent les hommes de farid gagny
comptent désormais cinq points d'avancé
sur le 2e le ch est né le club se
rapproche petit à petit de la montée en
première division de district une
première pour le club c'est une surprise
c'est historique pour le club
après
moi j'ai repris l'équipe en début de
saison avec pour objectif justement de
finir premières places par rapport au
potentiel de l'équipe je pense qu'on
mérite la première place prochain match
pour le magnifique boys club ce dimanche
à 15 heures contre marly le roi un
adversaire qui pointe à la 10e place du
classement les saint quentinois veulent
l'emporter pour valider leur monter le
plus rapidement possible après le
football est la belle victoire de manier
la mort on passe à l'eco trail de paris
ile-de-france l'illinois patrick guérin
va courir pour l'association aliénor la
huitième édition de l'eco trail paris
ile de france est programmée ce samedi
le départ sera donné à midi depuis ville
li le loisir de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la course fait
80 km parmi les participants on
retrouvera patrick guérin qui
participera à la compétition pour
l'association aliénor alors bon sens
patrick bon choix alors vous êtes venu
accompagné de deux élèves aussi dont
vous soutenir dans cette aventure
voilà donc avec celle courtinat élèves à
grandchamp saint quentin en yvelines est
allé à marie marque s élève à saint
vincent de paul à versailles alors
expliquez nous un petit peu votre projet
mais écoutez c'est un projet qui a
débuté ici-même il ya deux ans où suite
à différentes opérations qu'on a monté
lors des journées de la santé au niveau
du lycée saint vincent de paul on a
décidé de réitérer un partenariat avec
l'association aliénor et puis m'est
venue l'idée de les soutenir et pour les
soutenir j'ai lié passion sportive avec
je dirais le besoin de créer une
émulation pédagogique avec les élèves et
puis de pouvoir fournir une aide
matérielle à l'association aliénor sous
forme de dons a déjà récolté plus de
3000 euros de dons en deux ans voilà
exactement c'est pour acheter un chien
le but c'est participer à l'achat d'un
chien ça coûte très cher
on élève quatre chiens pour en avoir un
réellement valable pour accompagner un
non voyant et savoir que pour un non
voyant c'est la garantie d'avoir de
l'autonomie donc la socialite
sociabilisation
ce qui n'est pas négligeable du tout
voilà et marie marquez du coup vous le
connaissez d'autres comme un temps
patrick guérin et où le soutenait depuis
combien de temps du coup ça va faire la
troisième année cette année depuis on a
commencé le projet avec monsieur guérin
depuis la seconde et du coup qu'est ce
qui vous a plus accès à l'eau justement
dans ce dans ce projet bon pourquoi le
devenir patrick bassot le temps faim ça
permet du coup d'avoir une petite
activité sportive et ensuite avoir en
fin de cours pour la bonne cause du coup
en plus et donc de récolter des dons et
soutenir aussi prof d'arrière et avoir
une autre vision du prof que en cours
tout simplement
et ça vous l'avez soutenu tout de suite
dès que quand ça s'est passé justement
ça cette approche vous êtes moi je leur
ai expliqué lorsque je me suis présenté
en début d'année ma passion sportive la
course à pied entre autres et puis petit
à petit jeu les a amenés à réfléchir sur
un projet vous pouvez monter
sachant que je connais simple à la
finalité du projet et ils ont à dire
assez rapidement
ils ont été initiateur de pas mal de
choses pour réunir des dons lors des
stages au sein de la famille parce que
c'est la solution la plaie de la plus
simple au départ il y en a quand même
fait des réunions type entre guillemets
tupperware au sein du conseil de famille
pour réunir l'ensemble de la famille ont
réellement et pouvoir avoir le maximum
d'écouté et de dons en conséquence ont
ils ont fait des actions basiques du
type gâteaux crêpes en vente au lycée
pendant les heures de pause
et puis ils ont vendu aussi le projet
auprès des autres classes et du coup on
a des élèves qui sont assez débrouillard
et kiwis du coup c'est assez un projet
donc sportif avant tout cette eco drive
où l'avait préparée comment de mon côté
ça se prépare par un mois al avance le
plus dur entre guillemets c'est que
c'est au printemps et que l'hiver est
assez long donc l'hiver c'est courir la
nuit
c'est après les journées de travail
courir tard le soir courir tout le matin
éventuellement ces trois quatre fois par
semaine dont une sortie de vtt pour
varier un peu les fatigues musculaires
on va dire par contre ça se fait avec ça
se fait malgré tout avec plaisir parce
que l'habitant les yvelines
bah c'est une région qui est verte donc
on n'a pas besoin de prendre la voiture
pour aller courir on a rapidement les
baskets et et c'est parti et justement
vous êtes entré les goûts alors
principalement sur cheuvreux
dans la mérantaise derrière sur la
millière dans tous ces coins là qui sont
super agréable on n'est pas les seuls et
on s'aperçoit qu'à course à pied
pourront plus vraiment de plus en plus
soin et vos accès vous l'avez vous
l'avez soutenu penser entraînement juste
avant nous on a déjà fait plusieurs
fonctionnaires ensemble et puis après
moi je m'entraîne aussi tout seul donc
plusieurs traitements pareil par semaine
donc voilà on se soutient celle qui se
débrouille bien qu'il se fait de plus en
plus à la course à pied et puis du coup
qui va donc tuellement intervenir sur
les côtes raides comme rendant visite à
des points stratégiques
voilà et vous espérez juste peut-être
susciter peut-être des vocations par
avoir la course
alors on allait susciter auprès des
élèves et puis on allait susciter au
niveau des professeurs du lycée
saint-vincent-de-paul et j'espère des
autres qui vont s'inscrire entre autres
par exemple on va faire une équipe pour
le mode d on va faire une équipe pour
paris versailles et petit à petit on va
gagner on va gagner je pense en nombre
et puis on va gagner en motivation au
fur et à mesure donc vous ont parlé
d'entraînement tout à l'heure ça va être
une épreuve quand même qui va être assez
longue donc vous allez arriver à 21h
21h30
j'espère avoir le faire nuit va y avoir
peut-être de la pluie
j'espère qu'on se prépare comment se
prépare justement comment on se prépare
il faut soit être psychologiquement soit
part d'une certaine façon oui alors je
cours heureusement ou malheureusement
pas avec la musique je sais que ça a été
une polémique au niveau sportif il ya
peu de temps
interdite sur certaines qu'on voit là on
accuse la musique dit est un produit
dopant
je dirais que ça peut aider dans les
coups de blues surtout sur des longues
distances
on est amené à un moment donné à se
centraliser un peu trop sur ses douleurs
on a un peu j'aime bien l'image le cops
en tête on lui coupe la tête il continue
à courir le cerveau envoie le message
comme quoi on a mal malgré tout les gens
continuent à courir perpétuellement par
perpétuellement pour le rebond une bonne
distance on va dire c'est un peu ça
après psychologiquement la famille joue
pour beaucoup les élèves
aussi je vous propose justement vous
vous laissez là vous allez le soutenir
du coup pendant l'épreuve ça va se
passer ça se passe comment marie donc il
ya des élèves plusieurs élèves qui vont
se rendre à des points stratégiques pour
pouvoir encourager le professeur est
toujours après les autres élèves qui
sont du coup moins sportive n'avait pas
participé les plans et du coup bas
envoyé des sms aux professeurs pour
motiver niveau axel vous allez courir
par contre plusieurs kilomètres sur
plusieurs points voilà pareille
stratégie qu'on va faire plusieurs
partis ensemble donc on verra comment ça
se passe et c'est bien que c'est bien
alors si c'est une première
l'évolution du projet c'est aussi là
dessus c'est à dire que conviennent
ponctuellement à l'arrivée ou au départ
ça c'était déjà fait et de plus en plus
maintenant sur des points stratégiques
écourtée courir partager une émotion un
événement un moment pardon et
ça ça va être un peu nouveau et c'est ce
que j'aimerais bien généraliser sur tout
les prochaines courses à venir aussi
et vous vous avez quel objectif
justement sur cette course est plus là
de l'objectif c'est de participer ou
c'est vraiment de faire un résultat
or personnellement ya toujours l'esprit
de compétition donc le corps et le
permet j'espère après c'est de le finir
de le finir comme il faut c'est à dire
bien
pas forcément dans le temps à partie ça
sera une option optimiste on va dire
après il n'y a rien de mieux je me
rappelle il ya deux ans l'arrivée de
l'eco-trail ou deux élèves étaient à
l'arrivée on a terminé main dans la main
c'est des émotions qu'on n'oublie pas
c'est des émotions même d'en parler des
fois ça me ça me semble vraiment génial
de partager la participation c'est ça la
semto voulez participer ça exactement
prenez un petit merci à vous trois
d'être passé sur ce plateau donc moi
personnellement je ne ferai pas cette
course parce que vous allez y allez
courage tout de suite on passe aux
résultats aux autres résultats du week
end ont commencé de série de résultats
par du rugby en promotion d'honneur 50
ans neeve il n'a rien pu faire contre le
leader du classement massif central la
défense du sky rugby a volé en éclats
sur cette rencontre les saint quentinois
se sont lourdement inclinés à
l'extérieur sur le score de 38 à 9
conséquence les ivy noir redescendre à
la troisième place du classement ils
sont désormais devancé par moments aussi
qui s'est imposé 38 à 12 sur le terrain
de stent à une journée de la fin du
championnat ou à mauran s'ils comptent 3
points de plus que les saint quentinois
avait avec un match en plus à disputer
toujours en rugby mais cette fois ci en
première série montigny le bretonneux a
remporté une nouvelle victoire sur son
terrain les hommes de cyril huriez se
sont très facilement poser 48 à 29 à
nouveau festival offensif pour montigny
qui a remporté l'intégralité de ses
matches à domicile depuis le début de la
saison
du côté du classement montigny le
bretonneux reste au contact du leader
alfortville lésigny montain totalisent
70 points 17 journées la montée jouable
cette année handball masculin le chesnay
a raté une belle occasion de pour
consolider sa deuxième place en
nationale 3 les illinois se sont
inclinés à l'extérieur sur le terrain de
neuilly en thelle
une équipe en difficulté dans ce
championnat qui pointe à l'avant
dernière place du classement
score final 32 à 27 une très mauvaise
opération pour les yvelinois qui voit le
leader lille prendre le large dans ce
championnat grâce à sa victoire contre
vitry le chesnay reste deuxième du
classement avec 37 points en ces
journées en basket très bonne opération
pour trappe les hommes de mustapha el
hafidi n'en finissent plus de gagner
ils viennent d'enchaîner un sixième
succès de suite à 2 à domicile contre
ormes et trappistes sont allés chercher
cette victoire avec leurs tripes dans
les dernières secondes sur ce match avec
un shoot au buzzer les équipes évinoise
ont fait carton plein lors de cette 19e
journée le chesnay s'impose à
l'extérieur sur le terrain de
barjouville 92 à 87 et poissy a dominé
malakoff 69 à 40
du côté du classement trappe se
rapproche des quatre premières places
les hommes de mustapha el hafidi se
retrouve à trois points du quatrième le
mans voici reste leader avec 36 points
le chesnais pointent toujours à l'avant
dernière place du classement mais peut
toujours espérer se maintenir en
nationale 3 en football américain les
templiers d'elancourt n'y arrive
toujours pas ils viennent de concéder
pour la quatrième fois consécutive ils
n'ont pas gagné
les yvelinois se sont inclinés 26 à 7
est empli n'ont toujours pas gagné donc
le moindre match cette année
au classement les saint quentinois sont
avant derniers du classement avec cinq
points engrangés en quatre journées la
course aux places européennes semble
déjà compromise les cougars de
saint-ouen-l'aumône son leader de ce
championnat élite avec 11 points
enfin du football féminin pour refermer
cette page résultats en promotion
d'honneur et l'encours s'est incliné sur
son terrain contre stade est pavillon
sur le score de 2 buts à 0 voisin n'a
pas fait mieux face à colombes lévy
sinois s'incline 4 buts à 2 à
l'extérieur au classement poissy
caracole toujours en tête de ce
championnat de promotion d'honneur avec
12 points d'avancé sur le second
voisin quatrième à six points de la
deuxième place ça va mal pour l encours
qui est neuvième de cette poule
c'est la fin de cette fuite sport je
vous retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau numéro très belle soirée sur
tv fil 78